This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中精神坚韧、体能训练以及培养韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些磨难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的姿态从另一端走出来。收听“2%”。也就是数字2，可在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在“Look Back at it”播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听“Look Back at it”。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯带来的《学得艰难》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《学得艰难》。2023年，“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控育有一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。大家好。
Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. I want to formally welcome you to the 300th episode of the psychology of your 20s. And it's not just our 300th episode. It is also the four-year anniversary of the podcast, which completely blows my mind. I don't really have the words to express how insane that is to me that I started this four years ago. It feels
欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们要剖析20多岁时的心理学。我想正式欢迎大家收听《20多岁心理学》的第300期节目。这不仅仅是我们的第300期节目。这也是该播客开播四周年纪念日，这彻底震撼了我的脑海。我真的无法用语言表达，四年前我开始做这个节目，这对我来说是多么疯狂。感觉
like it was yesterday and also a decade ago at the same time. It has completely changed, transformed, you know, just, yeah, just blown up my life in the most magical, beautiful way. And for the 300th episode, I knew I wanted to do something special. And I was racking my brain. I was thinking about it. And the one thing that people always ask me about that has nothing to do with psychology and kind of also nothing to do with our 20s.
就像昨天一样，但同时也像是一个十年前的事。它彻底改变了、重塑了，你知道，真的，让我的生活以一种最神奇、最美丽的方式爆发了。对于第300期节目，我知道我想做一些特别的事情。我绞尽脑汁。我一直在思考这件事。人们总是问我的一件事，它与心理学完全无关，而且某种程度上也与我们的20多岁无关。
is this thing right here. Is podcasting? How do you start? How do you do it? How do you make money from it? Why is it a good idea? Should I start a podcast? And my answer to that final question has always and will always be absolutely yes.
就是这个东西。播客吗？你是怎么开始的？你是怎么做到的？你如何靠它赚钱？为什么这是个好主意？我应该开始做播客吗？我对最后一个问题的回答一直是，而且永远会是，绝对是的。
But I feel like a lot of people don't really know where to start. It feels like the market is saturated. We have this deep fear of being perceived. And in many ways, I completely understand. because four years ago I was at that very place that I'm sure some of you are right now, wondering, is this a good idea? Is this something that I should do? And what I really want to talk about today is what I wish I'd known when I started. My best learnings, wisdom, advice that I can bring you from the last four years and over 300 hours, probably more at this
但我觉得很多人其实并不知道从哪里开始。感觉市场已经饱和了。我们对被关注有着深深的恐惧。在许多方面，我完全理解。因为四年前我就处于你们现在可能正处于的那个位置，心里在想，这是一个好主意吗？这是我应该做的事情吗？我今天真正想谈的是我希望自己在开始时就知道的事。我过去四年以及超过300小时（可能更多）的节目中学到的最好经验、智慧和建议，仅仅为了，你知道，带你们进入幕后。我有点打破第四堵墙。你们都知道《20多岁心理学》这个节目。我们不搞信息垄断。而且有某种东西，我要用一个非常陈词滥调的词，对于像播客这样的媒介来说是如此神奇和具有变革性，这让我认为它是一件非常特殊的事情。如果你能做到，如果你想做的话，
point, of episodes just to, you know, bring you into the behind the scenes area. I kind of break the fourth wall. You guys know at the psychology of your 20s. We are not about gatekeeping. And there is something so, I'm going to use a very cliche word, so magical and transformative about a medium like podcasting that makes me see it as a very special thing. And if you can do it and if you want to do it,
我真的认为你应该去做。而且我认为你应该拥有开始所需的机遇以及某种程度上的建议。所以这正是我们今天要做的。我们不会有所保留。我将带你回顾过去四年，它为我的生活带来的改变，起源故事，如果你们中有些人不知道《20多岁心理学》是如何开始的。我关于如何开始自己的播客的七个最佳实用技巧，以及为什么？如果你现在正处于20多岁，我绝对相信你应该去做。所以我想对每一位曾经听过一期节目的人表示非常感谢，
I really think that you should. And I think that you should have the opportunity and kind of the advice needed just to start. So that is exactly what we are going to do today. We are not holding back. I'm going to talk you through the last four years, what it's done for my life, the origin story, if some of you don't know how the psychology of your 20s started. My seven best practical tips for starting your own podcast and why? If you are in your 20s right now, I absolutely believe that you should. So I want to say thank you so much. to every single person who has ever listened to an episode,
感谢那些真正从第一天起就一直在这里的人。我知道你们有些人从2021年就开始收听了，而且你们每隔一段时间就会给我发私信，你们能陪伴这么久，这对我来说简直不可思议、太棒了。所以谢谢你们。对于我的新听众，欢迎你们。如果你来到这里只有一天、一周、一个月，
to the people who have been here since genuinely day one. I know some of you started listening in 2021, and you DM me every now and again, and the fact that you have stuck around for so long is just incredible and amazing to me. So thank you. And to my new listeners, welcome. If you've only been here for a day, for a week, for a month,
你对我和这个社区意义重大，我们不断将新人们引入心理学的世界，并为你的20多岁提供实用的解释。所以谢谢你们。你们每一个人，你们绝对改变了我的生活。我绝不是轻描淡写地说出这句话。因此，废话少说，我想把一些东西回馈给你们，特别是那些想要开始做播客的人。
you mean so much to me and to this community, and we are constantly bringing you, people into the world of psychology and into the world of practical explanations for your 20s. So thank you. Every single one of you, you have absolutely changed my life. And I do not say that lightly. So without further ado, I want to hopefully give something back to you guys, especially those of you who want to start a podcast.
让我们开始吧。所以，如果你不知道这个故事，如果你是一个新听众，或者如果你已经听过这个故事，我想我将再次提醒你，播客《20多岁心理学》以及现在的书《进行中的人》（Person in Progress）是如何诞生的，因为我意识到我好像从来没有坐下来讲过这个故事。你必须关注了一段时间才能理解它。所以在2021年，我经历了一次分手。实际上我经历了一次非常糟糕的分手。这是我的第一段真正严肃的恋爱。我以为这个人是我一生的挚爱，多么悲伤的误解，但同时又多么庆幸它没有
Let's get into it. So if you don't know the story, if you're a new listener, or if you have heard this story, I'm going to remind you, I guess, of how exactly the podcast. the psychology of your 20s and now the book person in progress came to be because I realized that I don't think I've ever sat down and given the story. You kind of had to be around for a while to kind of understand it. So back in 2021, I went through a breakup. I went through this really terrible breakup actually. It was my first really serious relationship. I thought that this person was the love of my life, how sadly mistaken, but also how great that it didn't.
以那个方式结束，我现在处于一段全新的、快乐的、健康的恋爱关系中。但我认为，我们的第一次分手有一种特质，它是如此剧烈的颠覆，但也无比神圣。在那段关系结束后，在那种悲伤和孤独中，我有了这个想法。当时我正在澳大利亚国立大学（ANU）攻读心理学。向目前在读或曾在该大学就读的任何人致敬。我当时其实在攻读政治、经济与哲学学士学位以及文学士学位。在我的文学学位中，我们有各种选修课的选择。我将我的专业选为心理学，我发现自己只想做心理学。
ended and I'm in a completely new happy, healthy relationship now. But I think that's this, there's this element to our first breakup that is just so wildly disruptive, but also sacred. And in kind of my grief and my loneliness after that relationship ended, I had this idea. I was studying psychology at the time at A&U, the Australian National University. Shout out to anyone who is currently or has been to that uni. And I was actually doing a Bachelor of Politics, economics and philosophy and a Bachelor of Arts. And in my arts degree, we had all these options to do electives. I'd chosen my major as psychology, and I just found that all I wanted to do was psychology.
我想修读每一门可能开设的课程。渐渐地，我发现自己不再那么关心经济学、政治学以及所有这些层面的东西了。我只想了解人类的关系、人类的关系、人类的心灵和人类的精神，我想，还有塑造我们的生物学，从心理学的角度塑造我们的一切。所以这些事情在我的生活中的这个非常重要的时刻交汇了。我正在经历分手，我想知道为什么它会这么痛。于是我开始阅读所有这些学术论文，阅读所有这些文章，你知道，
I wanted to do every single possible course that there was. And slowly but surely I found myself not really caring so much about the economics and the politics and all that element of things. All I wanted to do was learn about human relationships and the human relationships and the human mind and the human spirit, I guess, and the biology that shapes us, the everything that shapes us from a psychological perspective. So these kind of things intersected at this very important point in my life. I was going through a breakup and I wanted to know why it hurts so badly. And so I started reading all these academic papers and reading all these articles and, you know,
重温我学过的理论。然后我想，哦，哇，原来有这样一个完整的解释。然后我开始把这一点带到其他事情上，心想，哦，为什么现在找工作这么糟糕？为什么我的错失恐惧症（FOMO）如此强烈？为什么我会感到焦虑？这个“四分之一人生危机”是怎么回事？当我试图，我想，向自己解释这一切时，我的朋友们也会来找我。我们会在，你知道，围坐在餐桌旁或者一起学习。他们会把他们的困境带给我，就像作为朋友你自然会做的那样。
revisiting theories that I learned. And I was like, oh, wow, there's this whole explanation. And then I started bringing that to other things as well, thinking, oh, why does it suck so much to be job hunting right now? Why is my phombo so intense? Why do I get anxiety? What's this quarter-life crisis thing? And as I was trying to, I guess, explain it to myself, I also had friends coming to me. And we would, you know, sit around the dinner table or be studying together. And they'd bring me their dilemmas as you do as a friend.
而我忍不住说，哦，我的天哪，你知道有一篇文章吗？你知道有一位研究人员可以为你解释这个吗？正是在那里，《20多岁心理学》真正诞生了。就像我说的，所有这些，所有这些，你知道的，残酷但又神奇的、非常人性化的经历的交集。我以前谈到过这个，但是这个名字，《20多岁心理学》，感觉它就像是从天而降落在了我的怀里。如果你听过我们采访伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特的节目，你就会知道她有一个这样的比喻，
And I couldn't help but be like, oh, my coppet, did you know there's this article? and did you know there's this researcher who can explain this for you? And it was there that the psychology of your 20s was really born. Like I said, the intersection of all these, all these, you know, cruel but also amazing, but also very human experiences. I've talked about this before, but the name, the psychology of your 20s, it almost felt like it dropped from the sky into my lap. And if you listen to our episode with Elizabeth Gilbert, you'll know that she has this analogy
即创意其实不属于我们。创意有它们自己的生命。它们是自己的活生生的有机体，关于书的创意，关于电影的创意，关于歌曲的创意。基本上它们想找到最有可能让它们实现的人，最有可能赋予它们形式并让它们活过来的人。我觉得这正是发生在我身上的事，这个似乎凭空出现的想法其实已经是一个存在的想法了。它只是在寻找一个宿主，而我就是它的宿主。有了这个想法后不久，我就开始做播客了。我说的是在一周内，前几集，实际上前10集左右，都是在我的车后座上用手机录制的，
that ideas are actually not ours. ideas are their own things. They're their own living breathing organisms, ideas for books, ideas for movies, ideas for songs. And basically they want to find the person who is most likely to make them happen, who is most likely to bring them into a form and make them alive. And I feel like that's kind of what happened to me, this idea that just seemed to happen out of nowhere was really already an idea that existed. It was just looking for a host and I was its host. Pretty quickly after I the idea I started the podcast. I'm saying like within a week and the first few episodes, actually the first like 10 episodes were recorded on my phone in the back of my car, which was
就像一个超级丰田森林人，或者在我朋友的地板上，真的没有什么结构，也没有什么雄心壮志。我只是想去做。事情就是这样继续下去了。我进入了一段新的恋爱。我继续做播客。他跟我分手了。我继续做播客。我需要对你们非常诚实地说，在头一年半里，我没有任何收听量。这种情况持续了相当长的一段时间。我去了一家公司上班。我真的以为我的生活将作为一名管理顾问在企业阶梯上不断攀升。
like a super reforester on my friend's floor and there was really like no structure, no ambition. I just wanted to do it. And that's how it kind of continued. I got into a new relationship. I kept podcasting. He broke up with me. I kept podcasting. And I need to be completely real with you guys when I say that for the first year and a half, I did not have any listens. It continued along that way for quite some time. I went and worked a corporate job. And I really thought that my life was going to be climbing the corporate ladder as a management consultant.
我当时在心理健康领域担任管理顾问，帮助政府制定心理健康项目。我想，我真的很充实。我很开心。这就是我要做的。这就是我将要成为的人。然后，在2022年9月，发生了一件奇怪的事。突然间，像你们这样的人开始发现这个播客。
And I was working in the mental health space as a management consultant, helping out the government, make mental health programs. And I was like, I'm really fulfilled. And I'm happy. And this is what I'm going to do. And this is who I'm going to be. And then this strange thing happened in September of 2022. Suddenly, people like you started finding the podcast.
我总是被问到的最大问题是，你是怎么做到的？你是怎么让别人发现你的？答案是，我字面意义上完全不知道。我真的不知道。这甚至不是我在藏私。我是真的不知道。我当时没有社交媒体。我其实也没有做过嘉宾访谈。
The biggest question I always get is, how did you make that happen? How did you get people to find you? And the answer is, I have quite literally no idea. I really don't. And it's not even me trying to safeguard secrets. Like, I really don't know. I didn't have social media. I wasn't really doing guest episodes.
我没有出现在别人的节目里。我没有在里面投钱。我没有公关。我没有在任何地方被特色推荐。这完全是靠口碑。是你们。听众们把这个分享给其他人。然后在一夜之间，它爆发了。
I wasn't appearing on other people's episodes. I didn't have any money in it. I didn't have a publicist. I wasn't featured anywhere. It was all word of mouth. It was you guys. The listeners sharing this with other people. And overnight, it blew up.
我排在播客排行榜的第10位，然后是第3位。然后我排在第一位，排在乔·罗根（Joe Rogan）之上，排在所有其他人之上。这太让人害怕了，因为突然间人们开始在意我要说的话。直到那一刻，这还只是一个20多岁年轻人的胡言乱语。现在它感觉真的很严肃。很快我意识到，哦，这是我的召唤。这将成为我的工作。就像我投入了那么多精力的企业职业生涯，这个，可能真的不适合我。
And I was number 10, then I was number three on the podcast charts. And then I was number one above Joe Rogan, above all these other people. and it was terrifying because suddenly people cared about what I had to say. And until that point, it had just been like ramblings of a 20-something. And now it felt really serious. And pretty quickly I realized, like, oh, this is my calling. This is going to be my job. Like this corporate career that I invested so much in, like, this might actually not be it.
我很幸运，找到了一个来自美国的经纪人。她联系了我。我记得收到她的邮件时想，这是一个骗局。这完全是个骗局。而她才是那个真正说“你必须做出决定。你想辞职做这个吗？因为这会消耗你很多精力。你确实有东西。人们已经在听了。我认为我们能让它发生”的人。所以在大概2023年中期的开始，2023年4月，我走进公司，辞掉了我的工作。播客成了我的职业，成了我的全职专业。所以那也是两年前的事了。现在我有了另一个叫做Mantra的播客。我写了一本书。
I was so lucky I found an agent from the US. She approached me. And I remember getting her email and being like, this is a scam. Like this is totally a scam. And she was the one who was really like, you have to make a decision. Do you want to quit your job and do this? Because it's going to take a lot from you. Like you really got something here. People are already listening. I think we can make it happen. And so at the start of probably the middle of 2023, April 2023, I walked into work and I quit my job. And podcasting became my career, became my full time. profession. So that as well was two years ago. Now I have another podcast called Mantra. I wrote a book.
我刚刚在全澳大利亚结束了这个精彩的“与陌生人共进晚餐”系列活动，我们在那里遇到了100、200个出来和我们聊天并互相结识的人。我在小组讨论中发言。我有机会见到你们。这与我原本以为的生活走向截然不同。我总是试图用我的故事来强调，如果你给你认为几乎足够好的想法一个机会，如果你给自己一个机会，你的生活随时都可能为了更好而改变。现在我并不是说每个开始做播客的人都能辞掉工作，但我认为即使我当初没能辞掉工作，这段经历仍然会而且至今仍将是无价的。我想解释为什么我认为如果你正处于
I just finished this amazing dinner with strangers series of events across Australia where we met 100, 200 people who came out and chatted to us and met each other. I speak on panels. I get to meet you guys. And that is so different to how I thought my life was going to turn out. And I always try and use my story to emphasize to people that your life can change for the better at any given moment if you give the idea that you think is almost good enough a chance and if you give yourself a chance now I'm not saying that everyone who starts a podcast is going to be able to quit their job but I think that even if I hadn't been able to quit my job this whole experience would still and would remain to this day be invaluable and I want to explain why I think that if you are in
这二十几岁的话。
your 20s, you should start a podcast and it has nothing to do with money and it has nothing to do with success or visibility or fame or whatever else. It has everything to do with the fact that it is a completely eye-opening experience and it will open slash put up a mirror to the deepest parts of yourself. Let me explain my four arguments for why you should be doing this. Number one, starting a podcast in your 20s is basically a way of keeping a personal journal of the things you, you're going to be. You you care about and what you're going through right now. It is not for anyone else. When I started, what I really wanted to do was explain my own experiences and capture this like decade and all these moments that felt like so important. I remember being like, this is something I want to
在你二十多岁的时候，你应该开始做一 podcast，这与金钱无关，也与成功、曝光度、名气或其他任何东西无关。它完全关乎这样一个事实：这是一次让人大开眼界的经历，它将为你内心最深处的部分打开一扇窗，或者说竖起一面镜子。让我解释一下我建议你这样做的四个理由。第一，在二十多岁时开始做播客，基本上是一种为自己个人生活做记录的方式，记录那些你即将经历的事情、你在乎的事情以及你眼下的经历。这并不是为了别人。当我开始的时候，我真正想做的是解释我自己的经历，并捕捉这十年以及所有那些感觉极其重要的时刻。我记得当时觉得，这是我想
remember and I had this weird obsession with not forgetting things and with holding on to memories and podcasting was my way of doing that. A podcast acts as like this incredible time capsule for the point in your life that you are at now. And I really want to emphasize that it's not for anyone else, it's for you. And even if no one ever listens, this thing could live on the internet for years and years and years and years. It will live on the internet for years and years and years and how amazing would it be to be 35, 45, 60 and be able to listen back to the voice of you at 21, what she or he cared about, what they were going through, what they thought was fascinating, what they thought they knew about life.
记住的事情，我有一种奇怪的执念，就是不想忘记事情，想抓住记忆，而做播客就是我实现这一点的方式。播客就像是你目前人生阶段的一个不可思议的时间胶囊。我真的很想强调，这不是为了别人，这是为了你。即使从来没有人听，这个东西也可以在互联网上存活一年又一年。它将会在互联网上存活好多年，而如果到了35岁、45岁、60岁时，能够回听21岁的自己的声音，听听当时她或他在乎什么、正在经历什么、觉得什么很迷人、觉得自己对生活有多少了解，这该有多么神奇啊。
The second reason why I think podcasting is a really important endeavor if you were in your 20s is that it teaches you to really follow through. So this was another element of the story that I didn't really talk about. And it was that I was very, very lost when I started the psychology of your 20s. I actually didn't have my corporate job yet. I didn't have any job offers. I was about to graduate. In fact, I think I had already graduated for one of my degrees.
我认为在二十多岁时做播客是一个非常重要的事情的第二个原因，是它教会你如何真正坚持到底。所以这也是我没有真正谈到的故事的另一个部分。那就是当我开始做《二十多岁的心理学》时，我感到非常非常迷茫。我甚至还没有找到企业的工作。我没有任何工作offer。我快要毕业了。事实上，我想我已经完成了一个学位的毕业。
And I had no clue what I was. I was doing and I just felt this overwhelming sense of like the path in front of me is going to always be me doing things for other people and it feels very like laid out like I graduated I get the job I do this I do this I do this and I hadn't really challenged myself and I hadn't really given myself a goal to follow through on that wasn't according to a timeline that was given to me so to explain it like obviously I had a goal of graduating university but that kind of felt expected. I had a goal of getting a job, but again, I needed to make money. And I was like, when was the last time I actually did something for myself because I wanted to prove that I could
我完全不知道自己。我在做什么，我只是感到一种压倒性的感觉，仿佛我眼前的道路将永远是我为别人做事情，而且感觉非常死板，就像我毕业了，找工作，做这个，做这个，做这个，而我并没有真正挑战过自己，也没有给自己设定一个必须要坚持到底的目标，这个目标不是根据别人给我的时间线来的。所以解释一下，很明显我有大学毕业的目标，但那感觉是理所当然的。我有一个找工作目标，但同样地，我需要赚钱。我想的是，我上一次真正为自己做点什么是因为我想证明自己能够
do it and I wanted to follow through? And podcasting really gave me that opportunity to trust myself and to say to myself, I'm setting a goal. I'm doing this not because anyone else is going to give me praise or it's going to give me an award. I'm doing it just for me. And I have the motivation and the capabilities and the trust in myself to do it, even if no one else is watching. So that's the second reason why I think it's really important to have a podcast or do some, have some kind of project that is just personal to you. The third reason why I think it's so invaluable is that it allows you to climb cringe mountain. You've probably heard this, but so many people these days say something along the lines of everyone has a podcast now. Everyone does this nowadays. And it's kind of set in
做到并且坚持到底是什么时候？做播客真正给了我这样一个机会去信任自己，对自己说，我设定了一个目标。我做这件事不是因为任何人会给我赞扬或给我一个奖项。我这么做纯粹是为了我自己。而且我有动力、有能力并且相信自己能够做到，即使没有人在看。这就是为什么我认为拥有一个播客或者做某种只属于你个人的项目真的很重要的第二个原因。我认为它如此无可替代的第三个原因，是它能让你去攀登“尴尬山”。你可能听说过这个，但现在很多人都会说这样的话：现在每个人都有播客。现在每个人都在做这个。这在某种程度上
a way to, I don't know, tear down the people who do it and to discourage people from trying and to make it seem like this is easy and anyone can do it and it's not valuable. I have a theory. The people who always say that, and I've heard it before, I think they actually secretly want to do it, but they don't have the courage. And so they have to convince themselves that this thing isn't desirable as a way to not look in the mirror and realize that they actually just don't have the courage to do it. They don't have the bravery.
是为了，我不知道，去贬低那些做播客的人，打击人们尝试的积极性，让它看起来很简单，任何人都能做，而且没有什么价值。我有一个理论。那些总是这样说的人，我也听说过，我认为他们其实内心深处也想做，但他们没有勇气。所以他们必须说服自己这东西并不吸引人，以此来逃避照镜子，不愿承认自己其实只是没有勇气去做。他们没有这份勇敢。
They can't put themselves out there. That is not going to be you. You are not going to be that person who belittles other people's ideas or who tries to downplay other people just trying. One of my guiding philosophies in life has always been that you will never be criticized by someone who is doing better than you or by someone who you admire. especially if that person is secure in themselves, because someone who has done the thing that you want to do is going to understand how hard it is, is going to understand what it takes to be successful,
他们不敢把自己展现出来。你可不能这样。你不会成为那种贬低别人想法、或者试图轻视那些仅仅在尝试的其他人的人。我生活中的指导哲学之一一直是，你永远不会受到那些过得比你好的人或你钦佩的人的批评。特别是如果这个人内心很有安全感，因为做过你想做的事情的人会明白这有多难，会明白取得成功需要付出什么，
and is going to understand how brilliant of an opportunity it is to just try. And so they will look at you and think, wow, I'm so excited for you. Wow, come and join us. Come take a seat at the table. The people who are going to criticize you for putting yourself out there aren't the people who are already sitting at that table. They're the people who are standing over in the corner, looking over and enviously and with jealousy and thinking, I don't actually want to sit there. But they do.
并且会明白仅仅去尝试是一个多么棒的机会。所以他们会看着你，心想，哇，我太为你高兴了。哇，来加入我们吧。来桌边找个位置坐下吧。那些因为你展现自我而批评你的人，并不是那些已经坐在桌边的人。他们是那些站在角落里、带着嫉妒和眼红的神情往这边看、心里想着“其实我才不想坐那儿呢”的人。但其实他们很想。
Podcasting allows you to climb cringe mountain and it allows you to understand that some people probably won't like what you have to say. Some people will think it's embarrassing. Some people will think that you're entering into an oversaturated market. It really doesn't matter because it's something that you want to do and that is the most valuable part of this exercise. I actually have a story for you on this. When I first started podcasting, I was dating someone.
做播客能让你攀登尴尬山，它能让你明白，有些人可能不会喜欢你要说的话。有些人会觉得这很尴尬。有些人会觉得你进入了一个过度饱和的市场。这其实并不重要，因为这是你想做的事情，而这正是这个练习最有价值的部分。我其实有一个关于这方面的小故事。当我刚开始做播客的时候，我在和一个男生谈恋爱。
And I remember him telling me that some of his friends thought that my podcast was in no uncertain terms lame. I remember him telling me about this one friend who said to him, oh, like, that Gemma's podcast is like kind of weird. And like that name is too specific. The psychology of your 20s. Like no one's going to listen to that. It doesn't appeal to a broad enough audience. and God, that's just so funny to me now because I have no idea. I have no clue what that guy is doing.
我记得他告诉我，他的一些朋友直言不讳地认为我的播客很逊。我记得他跟我提起过一个朋友对他说，哦，那个杰玛的播客有点奇怪。而且名字也太具体了。《二十多岁的心理学》。根本没人会听那个。它无法吸引足够广泛的受众。天哪，现在对我来说这真是太搞笑了，因为我完全不知道。我完全不知道那家伙在干什么。
But here I am getting to do my dream job. And I remember saying to the guy I was dating after he told me these things that his friend had said, I kind of indignantly was like, well, I don't really care if I'm not successful? Don't you see that? This isn't for applause. This isn't for visibility. This isn't for fame or whatever it is. This is because I like it.
但我现在却在做我梦想的工作。我记得在那个男生告诉我他朋友说的这些话之后，我有点愤愤不平地对他说，嗯，我其实不在乎我是否成功？你没看出来吗？这不是为了掌声。这不是为了曝光度。这不是为了名气或其他什么东西。这是因为我喜欢它。
And the fact that this other person can't see that shows that he has a real insecurity towards people trying because he can't. Finally, the reason I think you should start a podcast is because it's fun, firstly, but also it's a really good thing to put on your resume. It shows that you care about things. It shows that you have a passion. It shows that you have follow through. It shows that you can handle a project. I always get resumes from people who want to work for the psychology of your 20s. And if they have started a podcast, I will always look twice.
而另一个人看不到这一点，说明他对人们的尝试有着真正的不安全感，因为他自己做不到。最后，我认为你应该开始做播客的原因是，首先它很有趣，而且这也是一件很适合写进简历里的好东西。它表明你在乎一些事情。它表明你拥有热情。它表明你有始有终的执行力。它表明你能够驾驭一个项目。我总是收到那些想为《二十多岁的心理学》工作的人发来的简历。如果他们开通了播客，我总是会多看两眼。
always, even if I don't reply to them because sometimes I can't, but I will always check out their podcast because I think it's such a personal reflection of someone's, you know, in a self and who they are and what they care about and what they represent. And you know, if you're struggling in the job market at the moment, if you are finding that you can't get opportunities, it's a great way to make an opportunity for yourself and to leverage that into maybe a job or leverage it into an internship, leverage it into a connection and have this thing that you have made that says, I do care, I have skills, I can be a self-starter. So that is my argument first and foremost for why you should start a podcast in your 20s. I hope you don't need any more convincing. I hope you're
总是会看，即使我有时不能回复他们，因为有时候我做不到，但我总是会去查看他们的播客，因为我认为这是对一个人内心的真实反映，展现了他们是谁、他们在乎什么以及他们代表了什么。你知道的，如果你目前在就业市场上挣扎，如果你发现自己找不到机会，这是一个为你自己创造机会的好方法，并将其转化为一份工作或一次实习，将其转化为一个人脉关系，并拥有你所创造的这样一个东西，它在诉说着：我在乎，我有技能，我能主动发起行动。所以这就是我关于为什么你应该在二十多岁时开始做播客的第一大理由。我希望你不需要更多的说服了。我希望你
sitting there thinking, yes, I'm going to do this. What I want to now talk you through is exactly how and what I wish I had known before I started because it was a lot of trial and error. And now that I'm at this point where I think the error is a little bit less, I can share those learnings with you and I can give you kind of the blueprint and the roadmap to maybe getting to where I am, hopefully getting to where I am where you get to live out. What is an amazing career. So stay with us. We'll be back after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness,
正坐在那里想着，是的，我要这么做。我现在想跟你详细聊聊的，正是我希望自己在开始之前就知道的具体方法和事情，因为其中包含了很多的试错。现在我走到了这一步，觉得失误少了一些，我可以把这些经验分享给你，我可以给你一个蓝图和路线图，也许能带你到达我所在的地方，希望你能到达我所在的地方，去过上令人惊叹的职业生涯。所以请留下来。这段短暂的广告之后我们马上回来。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度背后的科学、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress.
体能，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，看穿那些统治健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为植物油本质上具有炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-HeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即I-HeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-Persent”。任何男人都应该遵守的两条黄金法则。法则一，绝对不要去惹乡下女孩。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也绝对不要去惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《闺蜜》的新一季中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？
The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。
On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我可以一整天都在聊快克，不过只是想让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以。谢谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《从痛苦中学习》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某样东西时，会太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们仍然在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同信任层次。我希望你真的能成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客中，我们将就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真实的对话。
Learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. So my best tips for starting a podcast, I took this very seriously. I was up last night after me and my boyfriend had dinner and I was like making all of these notes on my little iPad around. exactly what I wish I'd known. The first tip and the first thing you kind of have to, the hurdle you have to jump across is, what do I even want to talk about?
《从痛苦中学习》。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索“Learn the hard way”并立即收听。所以关于开始做播客的最好建议，我对此非常认真。昨晚我和我男朋友吃完晚饭后，我一直坐到很晚，在我的小iPad上记下了所有关于。我希望自己早点知道的事情的笔记。第一个建议，也是你必须要跨过的第一个栏目或障碍是，我到底想谈论什么？
How do you find your topic? The best question to ask yourself is what do you already talk about all the time anyways? What is the thing that fascinates you to no end? What do you chat with, with your friends? What do you like to read about? What do you like to watch? What do you really care about? that's your topic. I would really say don't try and copy what someone else has already done because
如何找到你的主题？问自己最好的问题是，你平时已经在滔滔不绝地谈论什么？到底是什么事情让你着迷不已？你和朋友们都在聊什么？你喜欢读什么？你喜欢看什么？你真正关心的是什么？这就是你的主题。我真的想说，不要去尝试复制别人已经做过的事情，因为
you won't care about it as much as your own idea that comes from your passions and comes from your interests. And people can really, really tell if you're just doing something because you've seen that it's worked for someone else and you don't actually care about the content matter. I remember someone actually started a podcast. This is awkward. I don't know if I should say this, but I'm going to. I have no ill will towards them, but it was called the philosophy of your 20s. And they started a while back. And it basically was a complete copy of what I'm doing. She copied my artwork. She copied my episode titles, my bio, my Instagram layout, my colors. And it really bummed me out. I was like, oh, I put a lot of time and energy into this thing.
你对它的关心程度，绝对比不上那些源于你自己的热情和兴趣的原创想法。而且人们一眼就能看出你做这件事是不是仅仅因为看到它对别人有用，而你其实根本不在乎内容本身。我记得真的有人开始做播客。这有点尴尬。我不知道该不该说，但我还是要说。我对他们没有任何恶意，但那个播客叫《二十多岁的哲学》。他们不久前开始做的。这基本上完全复制了我在做的事情。她抄袭了我的封面图。她抄袭了我的单集标题、个人简介、Instagram排版、我的配色。这真的让我很沮丧。我想，哦，我在这个事情上投入了大量的时间和精力。
This is like my entire identity. At that point, I was so, like, consumed with podcasting. I really didn't do anything else. And so it really hurt me. kind of. And then I was like, I know how much effort this takes. I know how much work is actually contained in making something you're proud of. And the only thing that's going to drive you to do that in that initial starting phase is if you genuinely care about what you're talking about. So what do you already talk about a lot right now? What do you already feel fascinated by? You're allowed to mix and match some things. Like you can talk about politics and you can talk about pop culture and you can talk about books, but you can also talk about music. And you can talk about dating,
这就像是我的整个身份。在那个时候，我实在是太投入于播客了。我真的什么都没做。所以这确实让我有点受伤。然后我想，我知道这需要付出多少努力。我知道制作出一件让你感到自豪的事情实际上包含着多少工作。在最初的启动阶段，唯一能推动你去做这件事的动力，就是你是否真心关切你正在谈论的内容。所以，你现在已经在频繁谈论什么了？什么事情已经让你感到着迷？你可以把一些东西混合搭配。比如你可以谈论政治，你可以谈论流行文化，你可以谈论书籍，但你也可以谈论音乐。你可以谈论约会，
but also about science. Like there's as many combinations as you want, just find what you care about. Secondly, my biggest tip here is don't worry about having all the gear. Just start with what you have. Sometimes having like the $5,000 microphone or even the $200 microphone can be discouraging because you feel like you need to make your production more professional at the beginning and that adds a lot of pressure which can really just be gasoline on, you know, the procrastination fire. Start with what you have. You can record with your phone. I recorded with my phone. In fact, you can go back and listen to episodes where you can hear that that is an iPhone, whatever it was, an iPhone 11. Like, it wasn't great. But I just started with what I had. And then as I
但也可以谈论科学。就像你可以有任意多的组合一样，只要找到你在乎的东西。其次，我最大的建议是，不要担心拥有所有的设备。从你现有的开始就行。有时候，拥有价值5000美元的麦克风，甚至200万美元的麦克风，都会让人望而却步，因为你会觉得一开始就需要让制作更专业，这会带来很大的压力，而这简直就是拖延之火上的汽油。从你手头有的东西开始。你可以用手机录音。我就是用手机录音的。事实上，你可以回去听听那些单集，你能听出那是iPhone，随便什么型号，比如iPhone 11。听起来不是很好。但我就是从手头有的东西开始的。然后随着我
got further along and I knew I had my follow through, I upgraded my equipment. what we're really focusing on here is consistency. That is the most important ingredient for you to have in the first three months. So if you're intent on starting a podcast, I want you to choose just one day a week, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, and force yourself to post an episode. Force yourself to post anything, even if it is literally a five-minute rant about someone who cut you off at the grocery. store, even if it is just your take on something small or random, even if it's like, it just, it can be anything. I just need you to start posting one day a week consistently. We know the science.
取得了更多进展，我也知道自己有始有终，我升级了设备。我们在这里真正关注的是连贯性。这是你在前三个月必须具备的最重要的要素。所以如果你决心要开始做播客，我希望你每周只选一天，比如周二、周三或周四，强迫自己发布一期节目。强迫自己发布任何内容，哪怕它真的只是一场五分钟的吐槽，内容是关于有人在杂货店插了你的队，哪怕它只是你对某个微小或随机事情的看法，哪怕它像是一随便什么内容都行。我只需要你开始坚持每周发布一天。我们了解过科学规律。
It takes three months to form a new habit. Three months for your brain to say, oh, this is something that we do. We are someone who makes a podcast. And three months for you to really adapt it to the energy and the effort needed and to feel like this is part of your routine. After that three months is up is when you can start focusing on other things. That's when you can start focusing on polishing your form, on improving small things about the content, about audio quality.
形成一个新习惯需要三个月的时间。需要三个月让你的大脑意识到，哦，这是我们会做的事情。我们是一个制作播客的人。还需要三个月让你真正适应所需的精力和努力，并觉得这是你日常生活的一部分。这三个月结束后，你就可以开始关注其他事情了。那时你就可以开始专注于打磨你的形式，改进内容的微小细节以及音频质量。
But in the beginning, you know, don't worry about video. Don't really worry about having the most perfect, spectacular audio quality. Don't worry about ums and ours. I used to edit on garage band. I still do. It's like the free software on my computer. I still use my phone for audio pickups and for ads and for filming. Podcasting is like the best thing to be a beginner at because people can't always notice that that's the case.
但在开始的时候，你知道，不要担心视频。不用太担心拥有最完美、最震撼的音频质量。不要担心“嗯”和“啊”这些口头禅。我以前是在 GarageBand 上剪辑的。我到现在还是这样。这就像是我电脑上的免费软件。我仍然使用我的手机来录音、放置广告以及进行拍摄。做播客是作为初学者的最佳体验，因为人们并不总能察觉到这一点。
Another element of this is also don't focus too much on social media. So I don't think I really focused on social media until maybe a year and a half in. Again, evidence of this. some extra time, scroll down to the bottom of my Instagram feed. At that psychology podcast, it was terrible. It was like Canva graphics that just look awful and I would just post like the cover of my podcast with a different title on it over and over again. And you know what? I think if I'd been too focused on, you know, the social media appearance or the visibility, I wouldn't have put the time and attention and the care into making the long form content matter. And I
这其中的另一个要素是，也不要过多的关注社交媒体。所以我觉得我大概在开始一年半以后才真正关注社交媒体。再次证明这一点。如果你有额外的时间，滚动到我的 Instagram 动态的最底部。在那个心理学播客上，它糟糕透顶。那感觉就像是 Canva 上那些看起来极其糟糕的图形，我只会一遍又一遍地发布我的播客封面，配上不同的标题。你知道吗？我想如果我当时太过于关注社交媒体的外观或曝光度，我就不会把时间和精力以及关怀投入到制作有深度的长内容中去，而且我
this all the time where people are like, I've launched the Instagram, I've set it up, I've got my fonts and my posts and I'm doing this and it's like, but you're not starting an Instagram. You're not starting a brand. You're starting a podcast. Like it's a different thing. Focus on perfecting the long form content first and then you can get to the decorations. Another tip, don't do guest episodes at the beginning unless it is the theme of your show. So what I mean by that is finding guests for a podcast is actually quite difficult and you want to find people that you align with and that are interesting and that will bring you something. I really think that at the beginning as you set the tone and the theme and the idea of your podcast, it needs to be you. Your voice needs to be the one who comes through.
总是看到这种情况，有人会说，我开通了 Instagram，我设置好了，我选好了字体和帖子，我正在做这个，然后就好像是，但你这不是在创办一个 Instagram。你不是在建立一个品牌。你是在做播客。这完全是两码事。先专注于完善长内容，然后再去搞那些装饰。另一个建议是，在刚开始时不要做嘉宾访谈节目，除非这就是你节目的主题。我的意思是，为播客寻找嘉宾其实相当困难，而且你想找到与你志同道合、有趣并且能带给你价值的人。我真的认为，在刚开始为播客奠定基调、主题和理念时，主角必须是你。闪耀的必须是你自己的声音。
So I would say for the first 10 episodes, make them solo. Unless obviously you have like a co-host, make it just you two. and then as you get further along, you can add in guests when they feel appropriate. And this is something that I still do to this day. I have guests really sparingly. Obviously, we have like the 12 days of guests in December, which is just an opportunity for me to really just talk to cool people. I hate to break the news, but it's entirely selfish. I still feel like guests are really important and I love learning from them, but my voice is the one that I wanted to come through.
所以我想说，前 10 期节目，都做单人独白。除非你显然有一个联合主持人，那就只有你们两个人。然后随着你取得更多进展，你可以在觉得合适的时候加入嘉宾。这也是我至今仍在做的事情。我邀请嘉宾的频率非常低。显然，我们在 12 月有“嘉宾 12 天”的活动，这对我来说只是一个真正与酷炫的人交流的机会。我很抱歉打破这个幻想，但这完全是出于私心。我仍然觉得嘉宾非常重要，我也喜欢向他们学习，但我的声音才是我想要传达出来的。
And it's the one that matters. you know, people, those people who are guests have their own platforms. And the reason they've been able to build their own platforms is because they understand that what people are really tuning into is you and is to your voice and your personality and your takes. So I know it can be kind of anxiety-inducing to put yourself in the spotlight on center stage, but it is really important for those beginning moments. I've got two more tips here. This one I also think is important.
而且这才是最重要的。你知道，那些作为嘉宾的人都有他们自己的平台。他们之所以能够建立自己的平台，是因为他们明白，人们真正收听的是你，是你的声音、你的个性和你的看法。所以我知道，把自己置于聚光灯和舞台中心可能会让人产生焦虑，但对于刚开始的那段时期来说，这真的很重要。我这里还有两个建议。我也觉得这一条很重要。
If you can't already tell, I obviously think all of these are important. Don't compare. Even 100 listens. 100 listeners is more people than your brain could even imagine. Like, I genuinely want you to imagine 100 people right now and give them all distinctive names and distinctive faces and professions and remember them all and you can't do it because 100 people, even 50 people is a whole lot of people.
如果你还没看出来的话，我显然认为所有这些都很重要。不要去比较。哪怕只有 100 次收听。100 个听众比你的大脑所能想象的还要多。真的，我真心希望你现在想象一下 100 个人，给他们每个人起一个独特的、有辨识度的名字，想象出他们的面孔和职业，并记住他们所有人，但你根本做不到，因为 100 个人，哪怕是 50 个人，也是非常庞大的一群人。
If you put all of these people in a line, you would be amazed by like, how big that number is. You know, at the beginning, you know, small numbers are really mighty. If you're not an influencer, if you're not a celebrity, it's unlikely that people are going to find you from your first episode and that you are immediately going to have listeners and have a big audience. And that's actually good because it means that you can try things out
如果你把这些人排成一列，你会惊叹于这个数字竟然如此庞大。你知道，在刚开始的时候，少量的数字其实也非常有力量。如果你不是网红，也不是名人，从你的第一期节目开始就有人发现你，并且你马上就能拥有听众和庞大的受众，这是不太可能的。这其实是件好事，因为这意味着你可以去尝试各种事情，
and that you're not worried about what other people think and that at the core of this experience, remember, like you're doing this for you, what kind of content do you want to make? And that's really my final tip. Have fun with it. Don't worry or start thinking about what other people want to hear. What would you want to hear? That is my biggest tip, actually.
并且你不用担心别人怎么想，而且在这段经历的核心，记住，你是为了自己而做这件事的，你想制作什么样的内容？这真的是我最后的建议。享受其中。不要去担忧或开始思考别人想听什么。你自己想听什么？这其实是我最大的建议。
Make what you would want to hear. That's why I think the psychology of your 20s has been so successful is because I'm making something that I already knew I would tune into. and so people who are probably like me would also tune into it. I wasn't trying to appeal to some anonymous amalgamation of a listener. I'm trying to appeal and make myself happy. And I think that makes it authentic. And it means that hopefully you guys can see that when I choose topics and I talk about things,
制作你想听的内容。这就是为什么我认为《二十岁心理学》能取得如此巨大的成功，因为我制作的内容是我自己早就知道我会去收听的。因此，那些可能和我相似的人也会去收听。我并不是在试图迎合某个匿名的听众群体。我是在迎合自己并让自己开心。我认为这让节目变得真实。这意味着希望当我说到某些话题并谈论某些事情时，你们能够看到，
it's not like I'm giving you a Wikipedia overview. Like I really want to know myself and I really want to explore that with you guys. Okay, I'm going to finish up with some listener questions. around how to start podcasting. I asked you guys over on Instagram at That Psychology podcast to send in your burning questions because I feel like people don't really talk about the like functional parts or the practical parts of creative work and yeah, I wanted to give you guys the opportunity to just ask whatever you wanted. This was our first question. What are the overhead costs of starting or producing a podcast? So this really ranges. You can keep them minimal or
这不像是维基百科的概述。我是真的很想自己去了解，并且真的很想和大家一起探讨。好了，我将以一些听众关于如何开始做播客的问题来结束这部分。我在 Instagram 上的 That Psychology podcast 账号上让大家发送你们迫切想要了解的问题，因为我觉得人们并不怎么谈论创作工作的那些功能性部分或实际部分，是的，我想给你们机会去询问你们想问的任何问题。这是我们的第一个问题。启动或制作播客的间接成本是多少？这个范围真的很广。你可以把成本降到最低，或者
you can get really expensive. I typically see it is occurring in three tiers. So tier one is the beginner's ideal point. It's recording at home on like a cheap $30 mic or on your phone using free audio software, editing on garage band and filming with your iPhone. If you already have a phone and a computer, which I'm kind of assuming you probably do, that means that starting a podcast for you is basically free. You then want to choose a particular platform that you want to host your podcast on. So this isn't like Apple or Spotify or IHeart. Your podcast does not live on one platform. It lives on your RSS feed. So you want to choose a hosting platform that works best for you. The one I use is Omni. I also use Spotify for podcasters or Odyssey or really good options.
也可能会变得非常昂贵。我通常看到它分为三个梯队。第一梯队是初学者的理想选择。在家用一个便宜的 30 美元麦克风或手机进行录音，使用免费的音频软件，在 GarageBand 上进行剪辑，并用 iPhone 拍摄。如果你已经有了一台手机和一台电脑，我想你大概率是有的，这意味着对你来说启动播客基本上是免费的。然后你想选择一个特定的平台来托管你的播客。所以这不像苹果、Spotify 或 iHeart。你的播客不会只寄托在一个平台上。它存在于你的 RSS 订阅源上。所以你想选择一个最适合你的托管平台。我使用的是 Omni。我也用 Spotify for podcasters，或者 Odyssey，这些都是很好的选择。
And it basically means that this is where you upload audio and then it distributes out for. for you. This is where you can see how many people are listening. This is where you can even edit or you can add in ads or whatever it is that you want to do. Choose one that works for you. For a beginner, I always say Spotify for podcasters. The second tier where it gets expensive is if you hire a studio. I see a lot of people do this. I wouldn't recommend unless you've been doing it for at least a year or unless you have, you know, it's for work or you've already got money behind the podcast because it is incredibly expensive. When I had to studio that I was paying for, which I no longer do, it was like $325 per hour, which is, I know that
这基本上意味着，这是你上传音频的地方，然后它会为你分发出去。在这里你可以看到有多少人在收听。在这里你甚至可以进行剪辑，或者添加广告，或者做任何你想做的事情。选择一个适合你的平台。对于初学者，我总是推荐 Spotify for podcasters。第二个变得昂贵的梯队是如果你租用录音室。我看到很多人这样做。除非你已经坚持做了一年以上，或者除非你有工作支持，或者你的播客背后已经有资金支持，否则我不建议这样做，因为这实在是太贵了。我以前租用录音室时，虽然现在不用了，每小时费用大约是 325 美元，我知道这
it's costly. It's not expensive because I know that that money is money they do need, like the studio, that is the cost of running a studio. But for someone who was, you know, that was like maybe year three, like I didn't have that money and it was kind of a waste for me, but that's when it can get kind of expensive. Tier three is when you make your own home studio. Now, this might even fall between tier one and tier two. It's kind of like a create your own situation. If you want to really elevate your podcast, you want to get a good mic, you want to get a good camera, you want to get a good audio software, and you want to get a good soundboard. And that's what I have now.
代价不菲。它贵并不是因为别的，因为我知道这笔钱确实是录音室需要的，经营一个录音室就是这个成本。但对于一个处于大约第三年左右的人来说，我当时没有这笔钱，这对我来说有点浪费，不过这就是成本可能变得高昂的时候。第三梯队是你自己搭建家庭录音室。现在，这甚至可能介于第一梯队和第二梯队之间。这有点像是一个“DIY”的情况。如果你想真正提升你的播客品质，你想买一个好麦克风，买一台好相机，买一个好的音频软件，还要买一个好的调音台。这就是我现在的配置。
So I always recommend a road mic or a shur mic, S-H-U-R-E. Those are incredible. Get like a Yamaha plugin box that you can plug into your computer. and the camera I'm currently recording on is a Sony, like a V1 Sony vlogging camera. That was all an investment that I made, but I think the total for all of it would have been around two grand. If you see people like Alex Cooper or Jay Shetty who have their own studios, that would probably end up costing around 20 grand. You know, they're building out cameras from multiple angles. They're building out mics that stand up.
所以我总是推荐 Rode 麦克风或 Shure 麦克风（S-H-U-R-E）。它们简直太棒了。买一个可以插入电脑的雅马哈插件盒。我目前录像用的相机是索尼的，比如 V1 索尼 Vlog 相机。这些都是我投入的资金，但我认为所有这些的总价大约在两千美元左右。如果你看到像 Alex Cooper 或 Jay Shetty 这样拥有自己录音室的人，那最终的成本可能高达两万美元左右。他们搭建了多角度的摄像机。他们搭建了立式麦克风。
They're buying furniture. but the best thing about podcasting is that it can really range for you. All right. I feel like I spent too much time on that question. But the next question is, how do you generate episode ideas? This is a great question. It's a combination of things that I'm experiencing,
他们购买家具。但做播客最棒的地方在于，它的成本可以因人而异。好了。我觉得我在那个问题上花的时间太多了。但下一个问题是，你是如何产生节目灵感的？这是一个很好的问题。这是我正在经历的事情的结合，
things that my friends are experiencing, things that I'm seeing in the news or online, that I'm like, hmm, there's probably some interesting psychology behind that. And also episode suggestions. So the last episode I did on emotionally immature parents that came from a little bit of, listener. Another episode that I'm doing coming up also came from a listener. It's on chronic
我的朋友们正在经历的事情，我在新闻或网上看到的事情，然后我想，嗯，这背后可能有一些有趣的心理学。还有听众的节目建议。所以上一期关于情绪不成熟父母的节目就来源于一点听众的建议。我要做的另一期即将推出的节目也来自于听众。它是关于慢性
apologizing. So that's kind of how I get my episode ideas. But I would say the majority of things that I'm currently experiencing or questions that I have that I selfishly just want to answer for myself, if that makes sense. But I find that, again, what's personal to you is what is going to be most informative and interesting to others. Question three, how long do you work on one episode for. So typically between five to ten hours. So the longest episodes, I find an idea and then I dive into the research and I'm reading sometimes 20 to 30, 40 academic papers that relate to that or website entries or watching TED talks that relate to it. So that research phase is normally around five hours in itself for really long episodes. Then I will
道歉的。所以这就是我获取节目灵感的方式。但我想说，大部分内容还是我目前正在经历的事情，或者是我出于私心只想给自己解答的问题，如果这说得通的话。但我发现，同样地，对你个人而言最真实的事情，也正是对其他人最具启发性和趣味性的事情。第三个问题，你制作一期节目要花多长时间？通常在 5 到 10 小时之间。对于最长的节目，我找到一个灵感，然后深入研究，有时会阅读 20 到 30 篇、40 篇与此相关的学术论文，或者网站条目，或者观看与之相关的 TED 演讲。因此，对于非常长的节目来说，仅研究阶段通常就要花大约 5 个小时。然后我会
write the entire script. So people always ask me, is the podcast scripted? Yes, it is scripted for the most part. I would say around 80% of it is stuff that is already written down and then I add my own takes in as I go along or if I have an idea of, I've forgotten to mention something, I'll add it in. But I find that having a scripted episode works best for me just because I don't want to give people false information and I want to be able to reference certain studies and certain concepts as best as I can. the recording phase for me, I've gotten it really quick. So I don't have a producer. I edit it all myself because I'm a bit of a control freak in that way.
写出完整的脚本。所以人们总是问我，播客是有脚本的吗？是的，大部分都是有脚本的。我想大约 80% 的内容是已经写好的，然后我会在录制过程中加入我自己的看法，或者如果我临时想到漏掉了什么，我就会把它加进去。但我发现使用有脚本的节目对我来说效果最好，因为我不想向人们提供虚假信息，而且我希望能够尽可能好地参考某些研究和某些概念。至于录制阶段，我的速度已经变得很快了。所以我没有制作人。我都是自己剪辑，因为我在某种程度上有点控制狂。
But I record directly into garage band. So I can edit as I go along. If I make a bad take, if I stumble, I'll just start the recording again from where I left off. And I can continue when I find that's easiest. And then publishing doesn't really take that long. I normally upload, put in whatever ads I need to. am required to buy my company and write the little description and then it's out. The other component of it is then promoting it on social media.
我是直接录进 GarageBand 里的。所以我可以一边录一边剪。如果我有一段没录好，或者结巴了，我就会从刚才停下的地方重新开始录音。我觉得这样最容易，然后就可以继续。发布其实花不了多长时间。我通常上传节目，插入公司要求我添加的任何广告，写一写简短的简介，然后就发布了。其中的另一个组成部分是在社交媒体上推广它。
That's something that I now have to do at the level that I'm at. That probably takes around, I would say, 10 to 15 hours per week. If you guys have seen my elaborate, like, Instagram posts that I do of, like, the episode descriptions, like, I put a lot of time and energy into them that I probably shouldn't. So that's definitely a big part of it nowadays. And then there's just other little things that come with podcasting that aren't to do with episodes that you have to do. So you have to talk to lawyers every now and again for, I don't know, copyright disputes. You have to record ad reads.
以我目前的水平，这是我现在必须要做的事情。这大概需要花掉，我想说，每周 10 到 15 个小时。如果你们看过我在 Instagram 上发布的那些精心制作的节目简介，就像那样，我在它们上面投入了大量的时间和精力，其实我可能不该花这么多。所以这绝对是如今很大的一部分工作。然后还有一些与播客相关的、与具体节目无关的其他小事，你也必须去做。比如你得时不时地与律师沟通，为了诸如版权纠纷之类的事情。你得录制广告读白。
You have to jump on calls with people who are handling the website or people who are handling, you know, whatever it is. So that also kind of fills in some of the gaps. and then now that I do video and I'm recording on YouTube, that's a whole other level. So I typically think that in a single week, I'd probably spend 20 hours actually writing and recording episodes. And then the remaining, I don't know, 15 to 20 hours doing other little jobs and little things like social media or other things like that. Okay, the next question. How do you handle things you want to share, but you know wouldn't make good content? I share them anyways. You guys will know I did an episode about a year ago on my mental breakdown
你必须开会接通处理网站事务的人，或者处理无论什么事务的人的电话。所以这也会填补一些时间空隙。既然我现在开始做视频并在 YouTube 上录制，这就达到了一个全新的层面。所以我通常认为，在单周内，我大概会花 20 小时来实际撰写和录制节目。然后剩下的，我不知道，15 到 20 个小时用来处理其他杂事和小任务，比如社交媒体或其他类似的事情。好的，下一个问题。你是如何处理那些你想分享、但又知道不适合作为内容的私密事情的？我不管怎样都会分享它们。大家会知道，大约一年前我做过一期关于我精神崩溃的节目，
on when I had a really terrible, terrible time for a couple of months and it was just awful and it was a really dark low place. Sorry, this has taken a turn but yeah, it was really rough. And when I was going through it, I remember being like, do I talk about this? Is this something that I share? And I remember thinking, no, don't share that. No one's going to want to listen to that. That, no, don't do it. It's too personal.
谈到了我度过了一段非常非常糟糕的几个月的经历，那真是太可怕了，那是一段非常黑暗低谷的时期。抱歉，话题有点沉重，但是的，那真的很艰难。当我经历这一切的时候，我记得当时想，我要谈论这个吗？这是我可以分享的事情吗？我记得当时想，不，不要分享那个。没有人会想听那个。那，不，别这么做。这太个人化了。
It's too private. It's too weird. People aren't going to trust you anymore if they know that you're really struggling. And I was like, whose voice is that? Because that's not my voice. That's, the voice of my inner critic is not my voice. It's someone else's. It's people from high school who believe me.
这太私密了。这太怪异了。如果他们知道你真的在苦苦挣扎，人们就不会再信任你了。然后我想，这是谁的声音？因为那不是我的声音。那是，我内心批判者的声音不是我的声音。那是别人的声音。那是高中时那些看不起我的人的声音。
It's teachers who didn't believe in me. it's ex-boyfriends who are cruel to me. What I want to do is I want to share. And that episode actually ended up being not one of my most popular episodes, but definitely one of my most engaged episodes. The amount of messages I got from people who were like, I can relate, I feel seen that is really what mattered to me. So I'll just share it.
那是曾经不相信我的老师的声音。那是对我很残酷的前男友的声音。我想做的是分享。那期节目最终竟然成了我最受欢迎的节目之一虽然不是最受欢迎的，但绝对是互动最多的节目之一。我收到了大量来自人们的信息，他们说，我能感同身受，我感到了被看见，这才是对我真正重要的事情。所以我会直接分享。
Honestly, I don't. There's certain things maybe I won't talk about, but the majority of it, yeah, I'll just share it. And if people don't like it, there will always be another episode coming out in like the next three days. The final question I have is, what is the piece of advice you wish someone had told you the day you started? I wish someone had told me that to do it well, it's a lot of hard work,
说实话，我不会藏着掖着。也许有些特定的事情我不会谈论，但大部分内容，是的，我都会分享。如果人们不喜欢，大概在接下来的三天内还会有另一期节目推出。我收到的最后一个问题是，你希望在你开始做播客的那天，有人对你说的一条建议是什么？我希望有人告诉我，要想把它做好，需要付出大量的辛苦工作，
but to just do it, it's not. And that it is so valuable and also to just start. It doesn't need to be perfect. You just need to start and you just need to get consistent and you just need to do it for the right reason and remind yourself why you want to do it. Is it because you want a time capsule of this time? Is it because you want a project?
但只要去做就行了，其实没那么难。而且这非常有价值，另外就是直接开始。它不需要完美。你只需要开始，你只需要保持连贯，你只需要出于正确的理由去做，并提醒自己为什么要这么做。是因为你想为这个时代保留一个时间胶囊吗？是因为你想要一个项目吗？
Is it because you want to forward your career? Is it just because you really care about something and you want to find people who also care about that? Remind yourself of the why. It takes time, but it is so rewarding. And you get exactly what you give it. Like you're going to get back every hour in terms of community, in terms of a sense of pride, in terms of this thing that is going to exist
是因为你想推动自己的职业发展吗？还是仅仅因为你真的很在意某件事，并想找到也关心这件事的人？提醒自己“为什么”。这需要时间，但回报极其丰厚。你付出了多少就会得到多少回报。在社群方面，在自豪感方面，在创造这样一个事物方面，你都会收获每一小时的付出，
and out there for as long as you live and that you can return to and which will make you feel accomplished, even if, you know, even if you never get a listener, it'll make you feel accomplished. So I want to thank you for listening to the end of this episode. If you made it this far, drop the name of your favorite episode down below. And if you haven't been listening for that long, drop the name of an episode that you want me to create and I'll let you know if we've already done it or I'll put it to the list. I'll add it to the list of whatever 200 plus ideas that we have, that we want to make into shows and into episodes like this.
只要你活着它就会一直存在于世上，你可以随时重温它，这会让你感到很有成就感，哪怕，你知道的，哪怕你从来没有一个听众，它也会让你感到成就感满满。所以我要感谢大家收听到这期节目的最后。如果你听到了这里，请在下方留下你最喜欢的节目的名字。如果你收听的时间还不算很久，请留下一个你希望我制作的节目的名字，我会告诉你我们是否已经做过了，或者我会把它加入清单。我会把它加入我们的两百多个创意清单中，那些我们想要打造成节目和像这样单集的创意。
Thank you for listening in general. I just feel so emotional. Thinking back on when I started and the times when I wanted to quit, you know, there was a period where I didn't make an episode for over two months and I think that could have been the end. And for some reason, I don't know why I came back. And I'm, I just, I'm, wow, I'm like, oh my God, I'm just like, thank God I did. Like, oh my goodness.
感谢大家一直以来的收听。我现在百感交集。回想起我刚开始的时候，以及那些我想放弃的时刻，你知道，曾有一段时期我超过两个月没有做一期节目，我想那可能就是终点。但出于某种原因，我不知道为什么我又回来了。而我，我只是，我，哇，我当时想，天哪，我当时就像是，感谢上帝我坚持下来了。哦天哪。
I, like, I just can't even think about what my life would be like if I hadn't. If I hadn't just been like, no, this is something I want to do. Like, it really changed my life. And I just, I really don't have the words for what my life is now. It's everything I ever wanted when I was a kid. and a large, well, almost all of it, it's because of the people who tuned in and who shared episodes and who followed along. And so this episode is really for you.
我，就像我甚至无法想象如果我没有坚持下来，我的生活会是什么样子。如果我没有坚定地说“不，这是我想做的事情”。这真的改变了我的生活。我只是，我真的无法用言语来形容我现在的生活。它是我小时候想要的一切。而且很大一部分，或者说几乎全部，都是因为那些收听、分享节目并一路关注的人们。所以这期节目真的是献给你们的。
And just it's a love letter to you guys, the listeners to say thank you, thank you, thank you so much for listening and for sharing. And oh my God, I'm getting emotional. But yeah, it just means, my God. I don't know what I'm crying. Yeah, it just means so much. and oh my god and yeah the fact that like now i've written a book and yeah i just met so many beautiful people and it just is i don't know i just never imagined it would be like this and yeah that like
这只是一封写给你们这些听众的情书，用来表达感谢、感谢、非常感谢你们的收听和分享。天哪，我又要情绪激动了。但是的，这真的意味着，天哪。我不知道我为什么在哭。是的，这真的意义重大。哦天哪，还有，事实上我现在写了一本书，是的，我遇到了那么多美好的人，这真的是，我不知道，我从来没想过会是这样，是的，就像
21 year old who was like heartbroken is now a 25 year old who is sitting here and who who has a book and who has two podcasts and who has friends she never would have met and you know a partner she never have met if this hadn't have happened. So thank you for listening. Oh my God, I can't get emotional again. But yeah, thank you for listening. And until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. Start that podcast if you have the desire. And we will talk very, very soon. Two percent. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I bring break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange
那个曾经心碎的 21 岁女孩，现在成了坐在这里的 25 岁女孩，她出了一书，有两个播客，还有了她以前绝不可能遇到的朋友，以及（如果这一切没有发生的话）她绝不可能遇到的伴侣。所以谢谢你们的收听。天哪，我不能再情绪激动了。但总之，谢谢你们的收听。直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。如果你有强烈的愿望，那就开始做那个播客吧。我们很快就会再聊。百分之二。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。
modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. Eighty-four is big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. We pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。即 TWO.%节目。在《回顾历史》(Look Back at It) 播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。1984 年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何在朋友、喜剧同行和最喜欢的作家的陪伴下幸存下来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。
It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games. This space is about black men's experience. having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere,
那是一个疯狂的年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾历史》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《难忘的教训》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历。进行那些在任何地方都绝对无法安全进行的坦诚对话，
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
但你是与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话的。有多少男人穿着西装或披着盔甲？这向世界发出了一个信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，请在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《难忘的教训》。在 2023 年，美国《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the iPhone. heart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是《陷入爱河的陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。请在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《陷入爱河的陷阱》播客。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。